today I want to talk about the
importance of storytelling so whenever
you're trying to convince anybody to do
anything whether that's a customer to
buy from you and investor to put money
into your company suppliers to give you
a good deal media to do a story on you
or you want your kids to do something
follow certain behavior you want to
persuade your husband or wife to do
something with you whenever you're
trying to persuade anybody to do
anything one of the most powerful tools
that you have in your arsenal that most
people don't use very well is
storytelling most people what they'll do
is they'll just they'll use logic
they'll use reasoning they'll give all
the reasons why you should do this but
it hits me on a very mental level
instead of an emotional level or if you
can use a story to tell me about
somebody who's gone through that and
took that action and change your life
and had success whatever the outcome is
that you're trying to accomplish if I
can connect to that person on an
emotional level if I can see myself as
that person and I want that same desired
result that I'm much more likely to take
the action that you want me to take so
here's how I stew my book in the book
there's a lot of theory there's a lot of
a lot of ideas a lot of information on
how to build and grow a business a lot
of stuff that is I don't want to see
counterintuitive but isn't necessarily
what's talked about a lot and I've use
these strategies to grow my businesses
and also help other people grow theirs
but a lot of it is theory and ideas and
just my story my sharing and what I
wanted to do was show more stories have
it be something that you guys can relate
to and so with all the points that I'm
going to be talking about what I'm going
to be doing is interviewing different
people at different stages in their
business
so this one guy who has fifteen thousand
dollars in business so he's built a full
time income for himself next one I was a
half a million dollar business than 1
million dollar business than a six
million dollar business than a 150
million dollar business and they're all
using the strategies that I talk about
in my book to build their business and
to grow and my hope is that by you not
just reading the strategies but also be
able to connect to these people
understand their stories and maybe one
or two of them you can say man that
person's just like me then you'll be
more move to take action because that's
the goal with the book I want you to
take action to grow your business to
have success to see growth to have a
meaningful impact on the world that's
the point and so whenever you try and
convince anybody to do anything you want
to use storytelling to your power the
more they can see themselves in that
story the more likely they're going to
want to take action the action that
hopefully you want them to take so as
usual it's time for Q&A and I only had
one question from last week lots of
great comments but only one question as
to mark Draeger who wrote in to say am i
allergic to mosquitoes mark i am i swell
up the itch like crazy the turn all red
and then white hate them it bugs me for
days and so I try to avoid mosquitoes at
all costs and if I know I'm going to be
out with them I use sesame oil because
it acts as a natural repellent that's it
guys one question if you have a question
for me that going to answer next week
though hopefully relates to the book to
this topic or something related to
writing your own book let me know in the
comments below and next week I'll make a
video response for you thanks for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon